big lats are one of the most important
features if you want to develop an
athletic and imposing looking physique
a huge wingspan makes you wider while a
dramatic
v taper gives you a super heroic
silhouette but let's do a lot more for
us than just that
in fact they do a lot more than many
people realize one of the most memorable
scenes featuring bruce lee is the
balcony scene
where he blows up his lats to cobra-like
proportions
bruce developed those lats for a reason
they helped dramatically with punching
power
and if you look at the backs of boxes
you'll see that bruce was not alone in
making that connection
this might come as a surprise
considering that lats are primarily
pulling muscles
but of course that's precisely the
contribution that the lats make
helping to snap the punch back and in
the case of a powerful one-two combo
this helps to rotate the torso thereby
throwing your entire body into a
juggernaut cross
that quick rechambering also gives the
punch its snap and prevents your arm
from getting trapped
outside of combat lats play a range of
other critical roles
they are absolutely central to rock
climbing for example which also makes
them crucial things like parkour and
generally running across rooftops like
batman like the glutes which they are
often used in conjunction with
the lats are anti-gravity muscles more
fundamental still
the lats actually play a huge role in
spinal stabilization
you might think of your lats as your
armpit muscles but in fact they
originate right down by the hips
coming from the iliac crest and lower
spine attaching at various points all
the way up to the inter-tubercular
groove
of the humerus they actually help with
the extension and lateral flexion of the
spine
as a result strong lats can help to
prevent lower back injury during
exercises like the deadlift
so how do we train them one of the best
use for building
functional powerful laps comes from
pavel tatsulin
no big surprise there pavel recommends
that the ideal pull-up should maintain
the same hollow body position
that a fighter adopts in the ring this
tactical pull-up involves contracting
the abs to pull the belly button towards
the spine
while engaging a posterior pelvic tilt
if you do this while standing with your
back against the wall
you should find that your lower back
touches the wall while your shoulders
round
and move away from it at the top with
that rigid position maintained
you're now going to perform a strict
pull-up with legs together and your
thumb is going to be on top of the bar
you're at the apex of the movement only
once your chin is above the bar
and you should simultaneously retract
the scapula this is important for other
movements like the front lever too
the hand position not only mimics the
way you actually use your hands when
climbing if you ever need to climb into
a window for instance
where you can't wrap your thumb around
the bottom but also subtly alters the
engagement of the lats
anything that adds a little flexion to
the wrist will increase lat activation
pavel actually has a fighter plus
program that offers the best programming
to use this type of pull-up
if you want to improve your overall
posture and resilience against injury
then improving strength endurance is
critical that said if you want more lat
power
then you can use the same program using
a weighted vest alternatively you can
try a lat pull down
in order to add even more weight while
the pull-up is a wonderfully functional
movement there isn't enough on its own
to develop the lats optimally
that's because the pull-up is a vertical
pull in my personal opinion training the
vertical pull only
is the equivalent of doing hundreds of
military presses and ever performing a
single bench press or push-up
doing a horizontal pull will transfer
better to punching grappling and moving
furniture
you can use the seated rail or bent over
row as an example of a horizontal pull
but i'm also a big fan of the body
weight row or inverted push-up
here you'll be lifting a small
percentage of your body weight owing to
the fact that your heels will be on the
floor
this makes it a great movement to use as
a mechanical drop set with the pull-up
perform as many pull-ups as you can to
failure and then immediately lower
yourself into the bodyweight row without
rest
i love mechanical drop sets as they
allow the development of both power and
endurance
i'd also recommend adding a rotational
element to your horizontal rowing
movements
there's a general lack of movements that
target the transverse plane in many
training programs and this is a much
better way to mimic the way you often
use your lats in real life
a great movement for this is the single
armed bodyweight row with rotation
this is commonly done with the overly
expensive trx but you can achieve the
same effect with a gymnastic ring rope
towel dip bar or parallel bar just as
effective as the single arm
standing cable row with rotation this
movement has the added benefit of
forcing you to brace your core and dig
your feet into the ground
it won't allow you to maximally engage
the lat so it won't build
massive size but it's perfect for
developing real functional performance
and teaching us useful movement patterns
for things like wrestling or dragging
things along the ground
keep the elbow in towards the body to
target the lats predominantly
when performing these movements you can
again increase lat activation by adding
a little flexion to the wrists
making sure to tuck the finger knuckle
under the bar when rowing
or to wrap it over the top of the bar
when doing pull-ups
but i advise combining a range of
different hand positions and pulling
angles
for the most complete back development a
great way to develop strength endurance
size and power in the lats is by rock
climbing
rock climbing is fantastic as you'll be
keeping continuous tension in the lats
and combining a vertical pull to move
upwards and a horizontal pull to keep
you close to the wall
especially when traversing you'll
naturally combine this with explosive
movements for things like dinos
along with every manner of hand position
unilateral movements and everything else
in between
i was big into rock climbing at
university and some of the guys there
had insane lats and unbelievable
gripping strength
it's also just a really fun way to train
don't have a climbing wall
if your gym has monkey bars then this
will work well too or you can try
climbing along fences or similar
alternatively grab onto your pull up bar
and try not only pulling yourself
up but moving around the bar vary your
cadence alter your grip
and move not only up and down but left
to right round and round
and just generally move yourself around
rope climbing of course is also
fantastic and i like to combine this
sometimes
with pull-ups so there you go there's a
ton of different things you can do to
build
bigger and more powerful and more
functional lats let me know in the
comments down below if there's anything
i missed and what you do to train your
lats you like this kind of functional
training that develops
usable real world strength and
performance then you'd probably enjoy my
ebook and training program
super functional training that's a pdf
with a full training program and also
tons of information
on different ways to train different
aspects of strength performance mobility
even brain function so if that sounds
cool then check out the link in the
description down below
there's a discount on whilst we're all
in lockdown
thanks a ton for watching this one guys
i hope you found it useful and
interesting if you did then please leave
a like and share it around
that helps me out immensely stay tuned
for much more like this
and i'll see you next time bye for now